it may look tranquil but beyond the
Still Waters of Lake Worth Lagoon the
home at the center of a political
earthquake
Behind These Walls at his Mar-A-Lago
Resort prosecutors claim Donald Trump
violated the Espionage Act
he kept top secret documents they
claimed strewn across this house
flaunted papers they say which
threatened National and Global Security
when FBI agents arrived some were even
spilling over the floor
the legal Jeopardy is cranking up but
his support at least here is Resolute
you don't think that there's any
legitimacy in these charges about
violating the Espionage Act even no I
don't we know that he's very boisterous
and we know he's kind of a show off but
he's an awful good president
this case is unlikely to reach trial
until after the presidential election in
2024 and Donald Trump Remains The Man
most likely to be the Republican nominee
if he is he'll be arranging campaign
rallies around court dates in two
separate criminal cases the implications
of this are extraordinary
he's staring down the barrel of some
serious jail time and I think that it's
finally starting to sink in just the
gravity of the situation and I think
that it would be in his best interest to
actually cut a deal because if he ends
up going to jail he's 76 years old right
now which means that he could ultimately
end up dying if he does have to serve
jail time so he could die in prison and
I'm pretty sure he doesn't want to do
that
at the local pickleball courts and
Maureen hoped the game is finally up for
Donald Trump I despise the man I think
he's a crook I think he doesn't know the
difference between a truth and a lie I
think he's so egotistical and looks out
for himself and really doesn't even care
about
this country and it's amazing that it's
not going to change some people's
opinion of trump
that includes their friend Jackie I
think it's a lot of showboating
by the Democrats because they know he's
very popular and uh I don't think it's
going to change anybody's mind either on
either side
Trump is hitting back in trademark Style
trying to Galvanize his supporters but
these challenges and the apparent weight
of evidence against him will be
difficult to defend against Martha
Kellner Steins West Palm Beach Florida